man i've been waiting for this
nba 2k tv what's this all about
hey guys i'm rachel and this is nba 2k
tv i'll be coming to you right here from
your game with updates on nba 2k15
features nba exclusives and 2k community
inspired content oh man let's see we
have some awesome new game features this
year so make sure that you guys tune in
to nba 2k tv to stay on top of your game
yo that's crazy a tv show and a video
game nba 2k tv will also include
exclusive interviews with some of your
favorite nba players coaches and
basketball experts cool
pound it
nice pajamas shaq but my favorite part
about the show is that you guys get to
help us create it nba 2k tv will give
the 2k community around the world a
chance to contribute be featured and
have a voice in each episode nba 2k
wouldn't be possible without you so we
want to give you a chance to shine just
like how you get to shine on our game
cover this year kd why are we talking to
me yeah katie i'm talking to you and
congrats on mvp last season too hey
thanks rach i'm just excited to get back
on the court and you know i'm gonna be
balling the nba 2k15 this season too
looking forward to the new episodes of
your show thanks kd and for the rest of
you guys make sure you tune in on
october 7th for our first full episode
of nba 2k tv
i'll see you there
until then i better get to work